hey guys it is the 26 of februari today
my name is Jess McDonald India watching
games but news the study has examined
why people buy we use Xbox ones and ps4
respectively and the differences are
actually pretty interesting according to
a nielsen study those who picked up a
ps4 tended to do so because of its
superior resolution first and foremost
other reasons included its blu-ray
player and processing power as well as
its game library as for the Xbox one it
was most chosen based on its brand
followed by its innovative features
processing power and games finally the
wii u was most often picked up because
of its fun factor kid friendliness price
and backwards compatibility as well as
its exclusive games nelson also found
that ninety percent of new gen console
owners previously owned a console from
last generation eighty-six percent of
wii u owners previously owned a wee
while seventy-six percent of xbox one
buyers had an xbox 360 next up if you've
had your eye on fable legends you might
be interested to hear that the game is
going to be free to play with a business
model inspired by League of Legends and
dota 2 lionhead have said that there
will be no gated areas or quests and no
energy bar to limit play time players
will initially have access to season 1
content that comes with a traditional
linear RPG storyline and side quests in
addition to 4th euros to players a
regular stream of updates for the game
will provide new quests heroes items and
whatnot all for free as for the money
making bit fable Legends is still going
to encourage you to spend your money the
four specific playable characters
available will rotate on a fortnightly
basis but you can buy ones you like
either with coins and by gameplay or
real coins and through real life work
times there were also because medic
items to buy and villains will be able
to permanently unlock the creatures
available to them by forking out coins
specific pricing for all those tidbits
is yet to be announced finally another
slew of Destiny screens of leaks today
thanks to Reddit and here are the
details the screams presumably show
content from the upcoming house of
wolves expansion and depict something
called a reef social space this seems to
be a non combat zone much like the tower
hub on earth at the moment the reef in
destiny is an asteroid belt the players
can only visit to view a handful of
times in story cutscenes how it will be
expanded upon hasn't been confirmed or
elaborated on by Bungie as yet the reef
social space might not even come to
fruition as bhanji have warned that the
images and areas in leaked screenshots
are not necessarily representative of
the upcoming content either way we'll
find out on May nineteen when House of
wolves is released let me know down in
the comments if you pay attention to
leaks game info and why or why not you
can head to Gainesboro we've got news on
Final Fantasy 15 and the upcoming Tomb
Raider film that is it for me today but
do remember that tomorrow I have my top
5 favorite stories of the whole gaming
week all ready to go pee so I hope to
see them